[Music]
why are people resistant to the idea
that dna has a powerful influence on our
personality
and our behavior i think in part people
are resistant to the notion
of the importance of genetics because
they don't understand it
and that's one of the reasons i wrote my
book blueprint how dna makes us who we
are
but you know actually i find there's
much more resistance in the media
than there is in the public i've given
probably 30
talks to fairly large public groups and
it's amazing to me
that i hardly ever run into hostility
mostly what i run into is people saying
i didn't know about that that sounds
really cool and the data sound
impressive
and people don't have a hard time
accepting
that inherited dna differences are an
important
answer to the question of what makes us
who we are it doesn't explain
everything by any means but the point of
my book is
that inherited dna differences is the
major
systematic force making us who we are as
individuals our personality
our mental health and illness and our
cognitive abilities and disability
these same genetic data provide the best
evidence we have for the importance of
the environment
but the environment works very
differently from the way we thought it
worked
and we can go into that in a bit can we
talk in more detail about
how genetics affects your behavior in
the ways that you're saying
yes there's so many background
issues to talking about genetic
influences
um on behavioral traits and one place
that i think is important to start
is with the idea of genes as destiny
i gave a philosophical evening
conversation last night on the topic of
do genes control our destiny because you
say genes
and people think of hard-wired
puppeteers
making us do things you know
deterministic
and part of that's because we learn
about genetics from mendel
and mendel if you remember did
experiments with pea plants
and he was essentially studying single
gene mutations in pea plants
if you were a pea plant you'd like your
seeds to be nice and round and smooth
there's a mutation a single gene
mutation that causes them to be wrinkled
so that these single gene mutations
are deterministic and hardwired and
necessary and sufficient
for humans there are maybe seven eight
thousand
single gene disorders most of them
thankfully are very rare
but if you had one of these like on the
tip of chromosome 4
you know we have 23 pairs of chromosomes
the tip of chromosome 4
has a gene that if if if if you receive
the inherit
of the mutated version of it you have
huntington's disease
which is a neurological degeneration
that happens later in life
and if you have that mutation you will
die from huntington's
it doesn't matter what your environment
is your exercise regime
your food it will kill you it's
necessary and sufficient
and so those are very important for the
people who get them but what we've
learned
in the last decade is that that's not
where
most of the genetic influence comes from
for complex traits
like those who study in psychology and
common disorders
like in medicine heart disease obesity
diabetes for example
there's strong genetic influence but
there's no evidence
for major gene effects that is any one
bit of dna is making a huge difference
what it's about this heritability is
about
thousands of tiny dna differences
that together have an impact on a
disorder
so that's a whole new ballgame you know
single gene genetics would be rather
simple you just
find the gene you find out what it does
wrong and you try to change it although
we're not very good at doing those
things
but here we've got thousands
of little dna differences that are
making you predispose
say to schizophrenia or in my case to
obesity and
it's a it makes it go from a
deterministic
hardwired single gene concept
to a probabilistic propensity
and that's what's hard for people to
understand so if i say
you have a 15 well in my case you know
my
um we put these thousands of dna
differences together and we call them
polygenic scores
my highest risk polygenic score
is for body mass index weight so
my genetic score just looking at my dna
alone it says
i'm about at the 94th percentile for
weight
my actual weight is at the 70th
percentiles
so i'm still you know borderline obese
but um you know this raises a lot of
issues about destiny it doesn't mean i'm
i throw up my hands and say oh well i'm
a genetic fatty nothing i can do about
it
which is what people worry about instead
i find it very motivating because i know
it's not
destiny if i don't eat i won't gain
weight
and then people like you know you know
many people in the audience will
just say well get a grip a little
self-control here don't eat so much
but people who like me have this
propensity to put on weight
and we don't really respond to food cues
in the same way
and and there's this sense of satiety
that psychologists talk about
that is if you're full you probably stop
eating and i sort of say at dinner i'm
out with friends
i'm full i don't want any more but if
there's food left on the table
as we're talking before you know it i've
eaten most of that food
even though i wasn't hungry particularly
it's just i don't have the same
sense of oh i'm full i absolutely don't
want
anything more and the other thing is
sensitivity to food cues you know when
we're bombarded by food cues
easy enough to say well you know just
get a grip resist those
things but i can't walk past the base
pastry shop for example the smells
my mouth is watering just thinking about
it you know
so um we need to respect these
differences and obesity is a great
example
because there's this stuff going on
about food fat shaming
you know people even suggesting that on
the nhs
if you go in for an obesity related
disorder like diabetes or cardiovascular
disease
why should the society pay for it you
know because it's your problem
well one answer to that is we pay for
lung cancer treatment for people who
smoked
cigarettes all their life and that's a
lot i would say because i don't smoke
properly
that would be an easier thing to resist
but you know people need to know
that and i bet this will surprise people
that individual differences is in body
mass index
which is weight corrected for height is
about
between 60 and 70 percent that means of
the differences between people that you
know are so apparent
in their weight almost two-thirds of
those differences
can be ascribed to inherited dna
differences
that came from that first cell with
which you were born
and that's the cool thing about dna is
it doesn't change
during your lifespan those inherited dna
differences that were formed uniquely by
the egg and the sperm that created your
first zygote
those that same dna is in every one of
the trillions of cells in your body
there are some mutations you pick up
along the way but the
systematic influences of heredity are
there in that first
zygote so that makes dna an incredible
predictor because there's nothing else
we have
that allows you to predict from early in
life and this is why medicine is so keen
on this this is why the nhs
is talking about making dna testing
available for everyone
because medicine there's two big
movements in medicine
one is preventive medicine and that's
the idea of instead of waiting for
people to have a heart attack
and then trying to fix it and it's said
that a severe heart attack costs 700 000
pounds all in you know there's a lot of
treatment afterwards and all that
let alone the personal suffering and the
reduction in quality
of life so waiting until something
happens and then trying to cure it
is expensive and it's painful if you
could
prevent that heart attack from occurring
it just is a no-brainer because you know
you save all that money you save all
that pain
and so to prevent you need to predict
and dna is the best predictor we have
from early in life
i mean sure you could say because i'm
overweight because i'm a male
because i'm over 60 i'm at on average
you know greater risk for having a heart
attack
but that doesn't give you much power in
predicting that i'm going to have a
heart attack
what's cool about dna is it makes a
specific genetic prediction
for me you know knowing nothing else
about these other characteristics
and and what's great about it with
cardiovascular disease is there's lots
of things you can do
to prevent art attacks i mean for one
the lowest tech solution
is to pay attention to the messages we
all receive
you know each well exercise you know
those sorts of things but we all kind of
ignore that
if you knew you were at very high risk
though for heart attack
you would pay more attention to it then
you can go higher up in the tech ladder
and
think about more frequent sorts of um
assays you know to to make sure your
arteries aren't clogging too much and
there are now these whole body scans so
you can
do more and more expensive things that
you can't do for everybody
but if you can identify people at very
high risk
it seems to be the way to go to prevent
and then the other thing
so the first movement in medicine is
preventative medicine
and psychology is trying to do this too
moving away from waiting until
you have a problem like obesity or
alcoholism
they're very hard to fix once you've
really had them
better to prevent them and alcoholism is
a great example because you cannot
become alcoholic
unless you drink a whole lot of alcohol
over a long period of time
so um that that's really great for
prevention but the other major
trend in medicine is what some people
call
personalized medicine or in the us they
call it
precision medicine so instead of giving
drugs
on a one-size-fits-all basis surely it
has to be better
to say that people with this genetic
profile would profit more from that drug
or that dose and and this is probably
going to drive it even more
there is always people with any drug
that it's really has negative effects on
them
and so if you could identify people who
will have a negative effect
a negative side effect of this drug
and you know it's not going to work for
them you don't administer it to them so
prevention and personalized medicine
are the reason why medicine is so
excited about this
and estonia and finland already make dna
testing available to anyone who wants it
if you go in the hospital and they take
blood they say would you like to
have us do this dna testing and we'll
tell you you've got risks for things
that we can do something about
and 85 percent of the people say yes
please i'd like to do that
and the nhs matt hancock wants to do
this
and um it hasn't happened yet
and with all corona and brexit and
everything else i don't know when it's
actually going to happen
but there has been 150 million set aside
to do this on a trial basis you know to
get it going with a few million people
so i find it tremendously exciting and
i've been emphasizing the positive
aspects of this and
partly that's because so many people are
saying
uh the sky's gonna fall if we do these
things you know it's
terrible there's identity issues there's
labeling issues
you know if you knew you were had a risk
for alcoholism
would that mean i mean people think it
means you're going to say oh well i'm
going to be alcoholic
but you know i never see that you know i
see when you identify a risk for someone
they might not do anything about it but
they're more likely to say
yeah i'm going to pay a little bit more
attention to this you know
and i think that's the way it's going to
work at that low
level of information that's why 25
million people in the world
have paid about 100 pounds to get this
dna testing
because they want to know about their
risk for things they also want to know
about their ancestry and all of that
so i think it's really transformational
and
i'm tremendously excited about it but
what i started to say was
there's plenty of people who worry about
it the doom mongers i call them
and you know that's really unfair
there's a lot of things we need to worry
about what about
you know ai getting a hold of our
genetic information
what about uh insurance companies
knowing that
you have a high cardiovascular risk
they're going to say
they're going to do their best not to
insure you or if they insure you
they're going to say this is going to
cost you a lot of money
insurance companies worry about well if
you knew you were at heart attack risk
and you didn't tell them that's this is
all illegal they're not supposed to use
genetic information you're not either
because if you knew it was genetic you
have it's like a pre-existing condition
it would be illegal not to tell them but
you know this is going to happen
both of these things will happen and
then the insurance companies would have
to pay out you know for people who
took a lot of insurance to cover their
risk
but i think the larger story here is i
don't see how the insurance industry
is going to survive the dna revolution
and i think this is the salvation of the
nhs
because the only way to get by in a with
the dna from
information is to spread that risk
you know and to say to have institutions
like nice the national institute for
clinical excellence
who says we start with debate you can't
do everything for everybody
so you've got to ration resources and
you say
in in our research this suggests
it's worthwhile you know this particular
drug even if it's expensive
it really does improve quality of life
but these other drugs that
say in in terminal diseases give you 10
an extra month or so
and it's hugely expensive they say we
can't really afford to do that for
everybody
so i think spreading the risk is
huge you know that that really does make
it important
but the second thing that people don't
realize is that
with an insurance-based system like in
the u.s
hospitals get paid when they treat you
for your disorder
they get paid when i have a heart attack
and they have to fix my heart attack
they don't get paid if i don't have a
heart attack
so there's nothing in it for them to try
to
prevent disorders whereas from a
national health system
that it's a no-brainer that's what you
want to do you want to prevent the
disorders from happening
so i really do think you know as
well covet has really made people
appreciate the nhs
but you know it has been underfunded for
a long time and it's one of the jewels
you know in the uk
that's one of the things in the world
people hold up as
you know there's an nh system that
really works for people at the point of
entry
you know and being an american i'm also
a uk citizen but in america
when people go for jobs you know not not
just the the lowest jobs but up to the
higher level management jobs they're
much more concerned about the health
care benefits
than they are about the salary because
the
with obama 10 of the people were
uninsured
it's now going up to 20 and if trump is
reelected it's gonna be
you know 50 50 i mean you know they
they you know i don't they hate
obamacare because it's obamacare i think
but you know it's such an amazing thing
to do but people without health
insurance they die
you know they have to be treated if
they're in an accident they have to be
treated to the point where they're
stable
but then they don't get more treatment
so
i just think this when people think of
the nhs as to the
throwback to the idealism of the
post-world war
second world war and you know that's
when all the big changes happen and
that's when decided that we should have
universal health care
i think now people think oh that's kind
of
past its time it's an old-fashioned idea
we need to have this be
market driven and capitalistic and man i
don't want people making
decisions about my health and my
operations
on a financial basis and that's really
what happens in the states
so i think this should be wonderful for
the national health
system i hope it is a picture of me how
would it work
how does it start to intervene in your
life
yeah well ideally and this is what matt
hancock is
moving towards everyone at birth
has dna testing because you only have to
do it once
and once you've got those three billion
base pairs suppose some
other genetic risk is discovered when
they're 15.
you know maybe there's some drug that
people have been taking that we always
thought was okay and suddenly you know
it's not
and you've got to do something about
that especially with people who are
genetically
sensitive sensitive so it opens up the
possibility
for the rest of your life of getting
information
that would be useful for you or
preventing illness
so um people say oh my god that's
gattaca i know you're too
young i think to know the movie gattaca
i've seen it and i know
um well that's older audiences that's
what they say oh
gosh that's like attica but people don't
realize we've been testing
dna testing babies at birth for 50 years
and the reason that started was one of
the first genes that was discovered a
single gene disorder
is called um phenylketonuria
it causes severe mental retardation and
in less than one percent of the
population
but pku is a single gene recessive
disorder you need two doses of it
and when that was discovered they
realized it was a simple metabolic error
error that's why it's called
phenylketonuria phenylalanine you have
trouble breaking down
phenylalanine and what happens if you
can't break it down is it builds up
and if it builds up in the developing
brain in the first few years of life
it causes severe retardation so much so
that most pku kids
that aren't treated would need to be
institutionalized they can't take care
of themselves
they don't talk you know so it's very
bad news
and um by knowing though that
it's this metabolic error you could
probably even figure out
well if the problem is you can't break
down phenylalanine
what if we eliminate phenylalanine from
the diet
and it's mostly in red meats and milk
products
and especially colostrum breast milk the
early breast milk is really high
in femality by doing that simple in
nutritional intervention you sidestep
the problem
so i mean that was so brilliant and that
was in the 50s and 60s
problem is you know so that's a perfect
example you find the gene you find out
what's wrong
and it isn't um a biological
intervention it's
it's simply an environmental
intervention so that's
brilliant the problem is there aren't a
lot of other examples like that
and partly that's because single gene
disorders are so rare
and most our big problem the real
medical burden
and psychological burden in society is
with these complex
traits and common disorders you know
things like schizophrenia and breeding
disability and alcoholism and obesity
and diabetes so these are not things
that are caused by a single gene and if
they're caused by
thousands of little gene effects it's
unlikely you're going to get a silver
bullet there that's just going to fix
the problem
you understand your inherited biology
your dna
in order to get a sense of what you're
more likely to be
up against but then it is up to your
environmental
situation and the decisions you make in
your life to try and mitigate that
it's not it's not just a case of biology
as destiny
no absolutely not biology is destiny it
and it's um informative um like here's
one tough
example if you do 23andme as as say 10
million people have
it's the biggest of these we call them
direct to consumer
dna companies dtc and
so it has about a third of the market i
would say
and one of the things you would find out
if you did that is whether or not you're
at risk for alzheimer's
if people know alzheimer's dementia laid
in line
now at age 80 10 of people
have at least the beginning stages of
alzheimer's which can last for 15 years
so a lot of us will have it at the age
of 10 at the age of 80
maybe 10 percent of the population but
if you
your results from 23andme could tell you
if you're in the unlucky one percent of
the population
that your risk won't be 10 it will be 60
60 now that's not 100
but as medical risks go 60 percent
is off the scale i mean that's a really
high risk
so for that reason about half of the
people including james watson
who won the nobel prize for double helix
didn't want to know
and if you ask an audience half of them
will say i don't want to know it's going
to ruin my life there's nothing i can do
about it now
but the other half which includes me is
i always want to know information you
know knowledge is power and forewarned
is forearm
so even though we can't intervene to
cure it now
that's the goal you're not going to wait
you're not going to
make people better who have alzheimer's
what you hope to do is to prevent people
from getting alzheimer's so by being
able to
predict genetically you're much more
likely to be able to find interventions
that work
so i'm optimistic that something will be
found before i'm
reaching that age it turns out i did the
testing and i don't have that risk
so but i mean if i had that risk though
and you know i had to say
if you do it with 23andme you have to
say yes i understand
how you know what a big deal this is
finding out about it
and then again you have to say yes i've
read about it i really understand it yes
i want my results and then you have to
say again
yes i want my results for this because
they want to make sure people don't get
those results unless they've thought
about what this means because
you know it could be devastating for
people and the worst bit about it is
in the end if you are in that one
percent you get a link that says
you might want to find out more about
this whereas you would hope if this were
on the nhs
they would say we've scheduled an
appointment for you to come in to talk
to somebody
and maybe bring a close relative or
something like that you know
um but people do divide down the middle
on this and i would say
i i want to know because i think there
is something you can do about it
that is if i know it's at a 60 risk for
having alzheimer's
i would first of all try to make sure
economically i'm going to be okay
you know with care homes for elderly
being [ __ ] you know we need to
maybe think more about protecting
ourselves
but then also socially i mean you want
to set up
things with your family to make sure
they understand and
you know so i think there are things you
could do but for me the biggest thing
i think would be carpe diem you know i'd
say i need an
extra dollop but you know instead of
thinking about oh when i retire i'm
going to do this and i'm going to do
that
i think a lot more about doing that
stuff now
so um it's a good example of it kind of
ties together a number of the things
that we've been talking about
you mentioned at the start when you talk
to people they're very receptive
but you feel like there's some sort of
buffer or
difficulty with the media and i was
wondering if you could just sort of
expand on that and
why it's hard for your message to
necessarily be communicated in the way
you want it to be
yeah well that's going to be my how the
light gets in
debate tomorrow is with um jasmine alibi
brown
who's very much on the left and lord
matt ridley
um who well i won't
make too much of a plug for it but we're
talking sort of about
science and politics and genetics and
should they
get mixed up but as alibi
uh john yasmin alibi brown will say the
left has been associated
with environment and the right has been
associated with genetics
i think that's incredibly simplistic and
not true necessarily
among friends i know and so
i would say you know even if that were
true why is the environment good
and genetics bad more harm by far has
been done in psychology
from environmentalistic perspectives you
know you
when i was in graduate school in the 70s
in the textbooks it would say
schizophrenia is caused by what your
mother did to you in the first three
years of life
man that is as weak as it could be
because you don't find out that they're
schizophrenic till they're 20
in the late teens or early 20s and then
you're told it's because of what you did
early in life which you can't change you
can't go back in time and change that
i mean environment does incredibly
wicked things and in
parenting which interests me a lot it's
mostly mother blaming that's the way the
environment works
you know kids don't do well at school
they have mental health problems it's
basically the mother
and mother blaming is crazy because
there's no evidence
to support that so what i don't think
the environment should be good
necessarily and i don't think genetics
should be bad
genetics can do a lot of good for us in
terms of predicting problems
and trying to prevent them before they
occur with personalized medicine
instead of giving kids with adhd
hyperactivity methylphenidate you know
an amphetamine which is what they do in
the states
10 of the kids are getting this and it's
increasing
in the uk well if you knew that some
kids would really profit from that and
it won't hurt them
you could predict predict that
genetically you know okay maybe
but undoubtedly some kids will actually
be harmed by that
and so personalized medicine and
prevention
i think are so positive that for me they
outweigh the negatives but i think we
have to have this discussion
but what i don't like is this knee-jerk
idea that if you're left
you have to deny genetic influence
which is really what it has been up to
now you know just
any sort of genetics was bad and that's
the way it was when i was in graduate
school in the 70s
if genetics schizophrenia is caused by
what your mother does to you in the
first few years of life genetics is not
mentioned
whereas now we know genetics accounts
for most
of the differences between people and
who become schizophrenic or not
and really how severe their
schizophrenia is i don't think there are
many people now
even on the far left who would say oh no
schizophrenia is caused by what your
mother did to you
i mean i i bet if we did a poem most
people would say yeah schizophrenia has
a strong genetic component
and if you're a parent you ought to be
damn glad about that because
you know here you do the best for your
kid you're as good a parent as you can
be
everything's fine until late adolescence
when they start
losing touch with reality they're
isolated they don't have friends and
and then eventually lose touch with
reality
you know that's devastating and if you
really believe
that you have molded your kid to be the
way they are
you don't consider genetics i don't see
i don't see how you can sleep fantastic
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you